c'est un grand jour aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire de la petite chérie de
mon amour de celle qui est là depuis le
début avec moi presque si oui presse
milliards que vous qu'avant mais s'il
vous plaît je peux faire une déclaration
à l'odyssée isabelle ma chérie d'amour
[Applaudissements]
isabelle déjà notre premier cadeau isa
j'espère que ça va te faire plaisir je
te propose qu'on fasse contre qui tu
veux un double de badmington ensemble
contre la paire costumes ce soir là
maintenant n'ont pas lâché l'info cumin
ce week end up
ce week-end je suis pas là mais la
semaine prochaine je veux bien sylvain
calonne tu as tes racines
donc tu organises je serai là pour toi
et bien à ben je vais partir
on va gagner on est à un autre cadeau
pour toi parce que bien un homme que
j'adore qui est un col agathois à la
radio quitte à laisser un petit message
pour te dire bon anniversaire
regarde c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui
t'aiment quelqu'un qui est dans la même
radio que toi regarde isabelle money
zabel je n'ai qu'un regret c'est que
nous ne travaillons pas ensemble sur la
première radio de france mais je me
console en te souhaitant un joyeux
anniversaire même si je n'ai plus assez
de souffle pour venir à bout de toutes
ces bougies et gsm
gc
et le canal antoine
antoine c'est la classe absolue ce mec
et je laime fort voilà tout me dire mais
la nikon petit mot merci antoine on
réglera ça la sortie mais travailler
ensemble je veux bien sur la première
radio de france donc bien sûr un soutien
sur rtl isa ya pas que sa peau parce que
vous savez je vous ai mises à et il y à
côté une salle pleine de cadeaux peau
regardez le principe est simple et sans
pièges bien entendu il ya plein de
cadeaux qui sont là oui l'amour en
enfance alors il ya des peluches pour le
kiff il ya des opposants qui feront
plaisir à isabelle hockey regarder cette
salle
elle est remplie de cadeaux elle est à
quelques mètres abel vous allez choisir
deux personnes de personnes qui vont
avoir trente secondes pour aller
récupérer le plus de cadeaux possibles
pauvres prenez les plus sportifs à mon
avis vous pouvez me choisir entre vous
les dents mais voilà deux personnes
vous pouvez me choisir également eh ben
vous avez raison mais si vous considérez
le plus sportif parce que ça va être
il va falloir être content d'avoir 30
selon il faut prendre le maximum de
cadeaux et revenir alors je vais prendre
un très sportif m'a forcément c'est vous
parce que les autres si je regarde pas
[Rires]
les pros
je veux reprendre un qui même si la
machine a tellement vers sa grande
gueule déjà depuis le début je vais le
choisir c'est jean-michel y est avec
plaisir il est sportivement mais il sera
réservé aux gens mais on va partir dit
si tous les deux on va avoir 30 secondes
pour aller récupérer le maximum de
cadeaux pour isa d'accord on isa chéri
mois déjà j'ai mon cadeau je voulais dit
oui je vous offrir aussi je vous dis ne
m'a pas tout une tenue de badminton avec
les plus belles raquette
[Applaudissements]
hormis attention c'est jusqu'à 6 passes
et fléchit apparemment ou trente
secondes pour aller dans cette salle
magnifique où il ya tous les cadeaux
attendent
[Applaudissements]
m
rien à 12 tonnes c'est vrai la tenue de
badminton c'est vrai